people the world's teeming with them I'm
a person you're probably a person and
everyone you know they're people too and
we're all different a bus driver isn't
the same as a candlestick maker your
local mail carrier isn't the same as
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and that's great because the
world would be kind of stupid if we were
all the same so let's see what we can
learn by talking to a real person let's
see what we can learn by talking to mr.
leather we've all seen beauty pageants
they're kind of weird a little out of
touch maybe a little polite I mean look
at this what are these what are these
hoops what this is boring the winner is
oh okay see ya that's what I'm talking
about
what you're seeing here is mr. Los
Angeles leather 2016 whoever overcomes
the stiff competition will go on to
compete against fellow mr. leathers from
around the world with the hopes of
becoming international mr. leather 2016
this hallowed contest has been held
annually since 1979 but before we dig
too deep can you sum up mr. leather in a
few words uh Miss Universe of the gay
leather world all right yeah that's a
few words that man on the right the one
who looks like an ad for sex Cologne is
international mr. leather 2015 Patrick
Smith the leather community is largely a
subset of the LGBT community and you
know it's for guys who dress up in their
leather and it makes them feel confident
and sexy leather culture has been around
since they say it probably dates back to
post-world War two when a lot of the
guys came back from overseas and they
remained in the coastal cities and wore
their hyper-masculine leather uniforms
nowadays though you see leather
including all sorts of people
masculine-feminine doesn't matter and
the contestants vying for the title of
mr. leather are all different sorts of
people young and old DJ's business
owners community activists fathers but
they've all got one thing in common
they're damn proud of who they are
what's involved with the contest you go
out you give a speech wearing your full
leather uniform you don't accountants
the audience and I know there are a lot
of hot kinky [ __ ] out there I would
be to represent you wear like one sort
of outfit for the whole thing or is it
like I know if it's all sorts of all
sorts of different look it's like Whoopi
Goldberg at the Oscar exactly you slowly
start shedding the clothing throughout
the night yeah yeah it goes into the
harnesses getting a little [ __ ] ha ha
ha
see just like Whoopi Goldberg at the
Oscars as the outgoing international mr.
leather Patrick sits behind the judges
table this year prepared to give up the
title but it's been a busy year for the
title is more than just looking good in
a piece of cowhide there's a
philanthropist side as well I spent four
years up in Canada working in politics
and a lot of people have done very
political things and activist things
with leather titles so that was sort of
what drew me into that aspect of it so
I've been traveling all over the world
to places where it's pretty scary to be
gay still so I went to Uganda I went to
Egypt and Morocco and the Ukraine and
places where people are jailed or
murdered just for being openly gay so my
goal was to go out to those places learn
what the situation is over there and
come back and do fundraising and raise
awareness for further situations and in
the same way that they fight for the
rights of the LGBT community at large
these guys also fight for each other
someone
I stopped including myself but it was my
leather family they were the one that
came and said David come back we want
you just the way you are when it comes
down to it the world isn't as accepting
as we'd like it to be but in spite of
that there's a lot of love out there the
friendship the support the diversity the
mentorship it is what defines us and
it's what makes us strong we open doors
for each other that is why representing
this title for you has been among the
greatest honors of my life
how does it feel after this year you
know it's bittersweet yeah on one hand
it'll be nice to have lazy Saturdays on
the couch back on the other hand it's a
really cool feeling
walking into a venue and everybody know
who you are and
and everything like that you're not
gonna be forgotten no no I'll fade
slowly into obscurity or like it I'll
just I love you Los Angeles it has been
a privilege and an honor thank you I
learned a lot from mr. leather but above
all else you should be passionate about
the things that make you unique where
your identity fiercely even if that
involves throwing on some you know so
nice assless chaps and letting those
little butt cheeks hang out yeah that's
a good thing to learn I guess
or mr. le leather 2016 Jeffrey